hi i'm donald morali i'm a photographer
2020 was uh i think for everybody on the
planet it was
quite a curveball i mean i don't think
any of us
have have seen so much in in
you know occur in one year i mean mean
to almost
i hate to say it to almost like biblical
old testament
things going on with you know things of
the environment
things with civil unrest for the last 25
years i've
been traveling and i i've been traveling
a lot for for sports and adventure and
other things
and um that all came to a screeching
halt
in march um i mean i i saw
probably 100 days of work just
you know fizzle and disappear within a
week the top event i was looking forward
to covering was the uh tokyo 2020
olympics
um which was going to start uh in july
obviously
that was postponed till 2021 but
for me that would have been my 10th
olympic games and i was very much
looking forward to
covering it for sports illustrated i
ended up you know
shooting more things close to home
whether it be you know just local
surfing or
things for you know social change
um you know local paddle outs local
demonstrations for for black lives
matter
um just different things that were
happening
in my neighborhood that i normally would
not be here for
so it was that was kind of a blessing in
disguise
you know what i i think nothing's going
to be the same after 2020 you know i i
don't think uh
you know we're going to pop back into
how we were before i i think
behaviorally we've changed as as humans
um because of what happened
um i i think um in general
um you know across the board i think uh
there's just things that are from
from this year on or gonna be the new
normal i really hope that
we get back to a place where you know
being able to to go to big sporting
events with with
all these people and the energy field
from that um
is is normal again and i think it will
be i think
by the end of hopefully 2021 by the fall
of 2021
you're gonna see pac stadiums again and
and
i you know i i do miss that side of it
where you're at these events and there's
so much energy
at them whether it's a sporting event or
even just going to like a music concert
with with people um all cheering for the
same thing
2020 in general was is
hopefully has been a learning lesson for
for a lot of people